uh some of our colleagues have mentioned
that they have concerns about
getting vaccinated but what guidance are
we giving to health care personnel about
providing
uh information to women who are pregnant
to make this decision about getting
vaccinated or not
congressman this is brigadier general
friedrichsen we are very closely
following the cdc
recommendations on that and providing
the same
evidence-based advice that the centers
for disease control
has provided on the safety of the
vaccines across the general population
and in particular for those who are
pregnant or have other medical
conditions
thank you thank you and i yield back
i've run out of time
thank you uh mr kelly is recognized for
five minutes
thank you mr chairman uh my first
question has to do
with uh 502f orders for folks who are on
cobit or uh service members who are on
kovid support
and uh while it's very important that we
be able to respond to this
it's also very important that we
maintain our operational readiness in
the national guard and reserves
and compo2 and compo3 currently
under dod policy when a service member
is on covet orders and they have an
at period annual training period uh we
have the 155th brigade that is getting
ready to go to the national training
center for a rotation
they have to come off 502f orders
which means they go back into national
guard status they lose their tricare
benefits for them and their families and
then three weeks later they go
back on covet orders with the stroke of
a pen
we can change that so that it is either
waived and they can stay on track here
while they go on those other orders
or we can just allow them to do a t
status during that
uh do any of you have any response if
anyone's looking at this because this is
going to impact
up to uh 3 500 members of the
mississippi national guard this year and
it's affecting soldiers all across the
nation
congressman major general nordhaus here
i believe that has been resolved through
the fema mas
um and that all the state needs to do is
uh
let them know which days that they're on
uh military and not
performing in support of the mission
assignments from fema
and then they stay on the orders and
they just complete the
reimbursable difference between those
days
that is great just make sure that we're
following through that all states
understand this because i know i dealt
with this i think last week and
that was in the initial stages that i
knew we sent out an rfi on that
uh second uh what em or what what amount
of our special operation
forces uh have been vaccinated those who
are
currently uh we had austin scott talk
about those guys downrange
what percentage of our special operation
forces have been vaccinated at this
point or do we have that number
so congressman we don't we don't have
that specific number with us but we
each each area is working through
allocations both at the
service level the combat command level
and the installation level to work down
the uh population scheme of priorities
so as as they reach uh critical national
capabilities
those um national response forces
would be um vaccinated at that time
and finally mr chairman and and also the
members i
want to ask them the emergency use of
the vaccine on service members and not
being allowed them to be mandatory uh
that just doesn't make sense if we're
saying the process
is safe we need to portray that in our
use on our dod
employees to set the standard and to set
an example
so do you guys on the panel do you think
it would be helpful if we change that in
congress so that emergency use vaccines
that they can be not shall be can be
mandatory to service members would that
be helpful to you
let me pass that to general friedrichs
congressman brigadier general friedrichs
thank you very much
i think that that would be a discussion
that we would need to have
with the centers for disease control the
department of health and human services
as well as the department of defense
it is going to depend on the specifics
of the vaccine in question and
i very much appreciate the continued
concern
about this issue uh no one is more
interested i think than
as we know you and the members of this
uh this
let me uh let me interrupt real quickly
my point is
if we say it can be it allows dod
to look at different diseases currently
we can't
make it mandatory and i'm not just
talking about this pandemic but the next
one and the next one
would it be helpful if we said
d-o-t-d-o-d
can not shall make mandatory can make
mandatory so that we can use the science
and the cdc
as each specific disease rather than now
having our hands tied
congressman speaking uh as a physician
it is always helpful to partner with you
and with our colleagues in the cdc and
hhs and crafting
language that allows us to respond to
each pandemic or biological threat as it
occurs
as you said they will each be different
it will be difficult to write language
that will cover everything but we look
forward to working with you on that sir
thank you the gentleman's time has
expired you're back
mr morelli is recognized for five
minutes
mr morelli are you with us
okay i think we just lost him so
um i think miss jacobs
are you online i'm here and
thank you uh mr chairman
thank you um and thank you everyone for
being here today
on this critical topic um to follow up
on mr brown's questioning
i want to thank you for offering to
provide us with the specific legal
authority that
you in conjunction with the office of
legal counsel are relying on to assess
whether or not you can mandate
you